invité de preuves par trois cette
semaine gérard larcher bonsoir soi et
merci d'être avec nous sénateur ump des
yvelines ancien ministre ancien
président du sénat une fonction
d'ailleurs pour laquelle vous devriez
postuler à nouveau si il ya un
changement un basculement comme
l'annoncent pour le mois de septembre à
la suite bien sûr du résultat des
élections municipales nous en parlerons
tout à l'heure avec perrine tarneaud de
public sénat avant cela vient bien sûr
nous allons évoquer notamment et que
deborah claude dans un instant notre
consoeur de la sp les annonces faites
par manuel valls lors de son discours de
politique générale notamment sur
l'emploi la fiscalité la fiscalité des
ménages mais également des entreprises
ou encore un sujet qui vous tient à
coeur
gérard larcher l'administration
territoriale de la france d'abord vous
aviez développer une absence de
dynamique dans la nomination et les
premières prises de paroles de manuel
valls et sk après l'avoir écouté vous
êtes toujours aussi sévère
d'abord je suis sévère sur la fin de
l'acte no 1
les 20 premiers mois et she sévères
vis-à-vis du président de la république
en fait en écoutant le discours
d'aujourd'hui aussi dit mais vraiment
quand il ya 20 mois nous disait que le
coût du travail ce n'était pas un
problème pour l'emploi quand on nous
disait que finalement on pouvait
uniquement avec des emplois aidés lutter
contre le chômage quand on faisait une
promesse que nous avions dit sur ce
plateau intenable vis-à-vis de l'emploi
je me suis dit c'est un mois de gâcher
et l'acteur
ça veut dire c'est zéro pointé et le
responsable c'est le président de la
république est aujourd'hui le zéro
pointé ça s'est traduit dans les urnes à
l'occasion des élections municipales où
nous n'aurions pas imaginé que nous
soyons sincères premier ministre a parlé
de vérité je vais vous dire la vérité je
n'imaginais pas même si j'avais parlé
d'un souffle bleus que le souffle soit
force 6 et bascule un certain nombre de
munitions
du coup et manuel valls dit vrai quand
il annonce une nouvelle étape du
quinquennat
en tous les cas un acte ii du
quinquennat où on va essayer semble-t-il
de répondre à la première question
comment on crée des emplois
on crée des emplois par la croissance
est uniquement par la croissance mais le
coût du travail n'est pas la seule
réponse est d'ailleurs m'a un peu
manquée le reste recherche développement
formation voilà des sujets qui ont été
absent du discours de politique générale
on nous disait il ya 20 mois que le
sujet n'était pas le coût du travail
on nous dit aujourd'hui le seul sujet
alors c'est le coût du travail on va
reprendre en détail les mesures qui ont
été annoncées pour le travail est ce que
vous estimez aujourd'hui que manuel
valls et la dernière cartouche de
françois hollande où je crois qu'en
politique il n'ya jamais deux dernières
cartouches comme pour un chasseur et
donc je pense simplement que aujourd'hui
françois hollande tourner le dos aux 20
mois qui nous a fait partager avec le
premier ministre héros et que tour dans
le dos il nous fait des propositions qui
sont des propositions qui aujourd'hui
pour les entreprises doivent permettre
de retrouver une part de compétitivité
nous ne savons pas comment vont être
financés parce que quand on additionne
sur la période ça fait 30 milliards et
mais aussi 20 milliards supplémentaires
qui sont extrêmement importants dont une
partie d'ailleurs avait été mis en place
par le gouvernement fillon sarkozy et
que dans un espèce de début de mandat
présidentiel il fallait absolument
effacer tout l'art doivent sarkozy on a
supprimé la tva
souvenez-vous alors il vous donne raison
a pas de manière sûre et notamment sur
le poids du l'urssaf et d'exonérations
parce que nous avions vécu en 2009 la
suppression de toute charge sociale
autour du smic savait créer trente mille
emplois et un rapport de deux économies
sur le sujet j'aimerais vous demander
avant d'entrer dans le détail des
mesures 1 de ce que vous entendez ce
comté pour les créations d'emplois alors
sur les gens et ça vous avez évoqué la
vague bleue des municipales est-ce que
vous pensez que manuel valls après
l'avoir écouté à la force pour faire
oublier la déroute électorale du ps je
pense qu'il n'a pas répondu par exemple
aux besoins de sécurité des français
il a fait un constat d'ailleurs assez
dramatique et qui a été la france jamais
assez dramatique y compris sur la
sécurité le sentiment de sécurité sur la
cohésion sociale du pays
je crois qu'il a raison mais il n'a pas
apporté de réponse et il a été pendant
plus de vingt mois de ministre de
l'intérieur
donc là un certain nombre
d'interrogations sur les questions de
société
autre point que aux nantais d'apaisement
oui mais en même temps il touche à quoi
est ce qui ne donne par exemple un
engagement du président de la république
sur le mariage par exemple le droit
d'objection de conscience
voilà un sujet qui serait un élément
d'apaisement et non il n'avait pas
question la loi la loi s'impose à tous
les élus mais je me la suis imposé donc
jamais mais je rappelle que nous avons
déposé avec bruno retailleau une
proposition de loi permettant aux mères
de retrouver l'objection de conscience
je ne me la suis pas imposé mais je
pense que c'est un droit aussi important
que le droit qui a été donnée aux
médecins en matière de fin de vie
manifestement on pourrait trouver de
nouveaux éléments a eu raison dans le
cadre de la loi léonetti père que nous
aurons sur ce sujet qui est un sujet
essentiel
un vrai débat un débat préalable celui
que nous n'avons pas eu sur la question
du mariage et que nous l'aurons
profondeur car c'est un sujet majeur
dans notre société
ça doit être un débat apaisé ouvert ou
s'écoute mutuellement et où la dimension
humaine
j'allais dire soit le coeur de la
priorité alors gouverner n'est pas à
rechercher la victoire d'un camp a
précisé manuel valls est ce que vous
pourriez soutenez un vol par exemple
gérard larcher la réforme territoriale à
la simplification du millefeuille est
annoncé sur ce point précis c'est la
quatrième proposition de réformes en
vingt mois je vous le rappelle nous
avons eu d'abord la suppression du
conseiller territorial
on efface sarko deuxième des choses
retrouve la compétence générale
maintenant pour le département la région
nous annonce assume sa suppression il
faut dire ce que ça veut dire 4 janvier
moins de quatre mois la loi est
promulguée
et voilà qu'on nous annonce à nouveau la
suppression de la compétence générale
que nous avions voté en dise que c'est
un ça et vite comme ça les doublons
qu'on pouvait rendre au départ bidonné
ans et région ne faut pas la même chose
voilà le département le social
l'aménagement rural c'est ce que nous
préconisons les grandes infrastructures
les grands projets le développement
économique aux régions et non pas un
petit peu en chacun ça va non seulement
mais dans le sens aix n'aurait pas bien
sûr d'accord mais je vous rappelle que
le gouvernement héros nous a fait voter
le contraire et le 19 décembre très
précisément au sénat je vais bien en
tête
vous vous rendez compte quelle cohérence
comment croire d'abord une prospective à
2021 sur les régions tu rappelles que
c'est un rapport
j'appartenais à ce groupe de travail
présidé par jean pierre raffarin dont le
rapporteur est et yves krattinger
socialiste et qui a prôné la réduction
du nombre de régions de moitié et
apprenez aussi que le principe
départementale ne soit pas un principe
j'allais dire général est que le
département nous en avons besoin dans
les territoires ruraux
peut-être que dans l'est autour des
grandes métropoles on peut inventer un
autre partage du social donc tout ça est
déjà inscrit dans les propositions du
sénat et dans ce type de débat
aujourd'hui qu'il faut retrouver de la
cohérence et de la sérénité et non pas
quelque part un espèce de règlement de
compte qui voudrait montrer du doigt que
ce sont les collectivités territoriales
sur le facteur du déséquilibre financier
français je vous rappelle que les
collectivités territoriales c'est 4% du
déficit du pays en annonçant 83% c'est
l'état et 13% sur les comptes sociaux
rien un tour de vis de 10 milliards
d'euros sur les caddies soyez je
remarque que 20 % de l'effort est
demandé aux collectivités territoriales
qui ne sont que 4% du déficit mais je
pense que les collectivités
territoriales doivent y participer à
l'époque j'étais président du sénat je
les pros des mais d'une manière qui ne
soit pas brutale avec en plus quelques
cohérence regardez un milliard le coût
des rythmes scolaires 1 milliard 4
chaque année les normes supplémentaires
ce n'est pas moi qui le dit c'est un
rapport qu'elle a été produit on va
faire le métier de ces réalités là vous
prenez
l'addition de l'ensemble et il faut pas
simplement montrer du doigt les
collectivités territoriales leur faire
peser des coûts je pense aux rythmes
scolaires supplémentaires je pense aux
normes des coûts supplémentaires et en
plus dire vous êtes le facteur de
déficit et sur la disparition programmée
des conseils généraux donc à l'horizon
d'abord nous on a un certain temps c'est
quand même fût du canon
et je pense que la proposition du sénat
qui avait fait un assez large consensus
sur qui portera demain la politique
sociale dans les territoires ruraux qui
portera demain la politique
d'aménagement du territoire rural
si ce n'est une structure est la
meilleure des structures elle est issue
de la démocratie et le conseil
départemental puisque c'est son nouveau
nom est ce qu'il faut le supprimer pour
en recréer un autre par contre là où
existent des métropoles de très grosses
intercommunalités
on peut apporter des réponses c'est le
cas à lyon par exemple il ya eu
consensus politique
donc je pense que sur la question
territoriale
faut arrêter de faire des coups de
menton il faut parler tranquillement
sereinement faire confiance aux
représentants des territoires que le
sénat or jusque-là et compris monsieur
val souvenez vous du débat sur le cumul
des mandats comme monsieur valls d'un
coup de menton dont il a un peu
l'habitude a dit vous pouvez toujours
discuter ce que vous direz ici n'a
aucune importance mais il va falloir
comme premier ministre si leur assemblée
qui l'écoutent le sénat qu'il écoute le
représentant les intérêts rapport au
scénario et c'est bien qu'il l'ait lu
cette semaine au moins celui d'à et il
aurait bien fait de le lire au moment du
débat sur le cumul des mandats car nous
n'avons pas parlé que de cumul des
mandats nous avons aussi parlé de
représentation du territoire vous avez
écouté le discours de politique générale
est ce que vous y voyez un reniement en
finalement de ce que prône et françois
roux de ce que disait françois hollande
jusqu'à présent sur le coût du travail
sur les compétences des collectivités un
remaniement il ya des virages vous avez
des le jeu il ya des virages à 180
degrés oui ça heureusement c'est comme
la promesse de la baisse du chômage à la
fin 2013 je pense que c'est aussi ce que
les français ont reproché au président
de la république pense qu'il ne faut pas
bercé nos compatriotes d'illusions et
voilà pourquoi des boues que j'ai aimé
vous dire que c'est le mot vérité
eh bien il faut dire la vérité aux
français la vérité aux français c'est
que ça va être difficile et qu' il ne
suffira pas simplement de baisser le
coût du travail pour retrouver de la
compétitivité faut aussi que nous
conduisions un certain nombre d'efforts
comme nos amis allemands ont conduit
comme douloureusement très
douloureusement j'espère que nous
n'aurons pas le vivre ainsi l'espagne a
conduit
on ne pourra pas rose simplement
responsable
la banque centrale européenne ou la
politique d une question avant découvert
écouter manuel valls sur le coût du
travail mais il ya des économistes
il ya pascal lamy par exemple ancien
directeur général de l'om c'est qu'ils
prônent aujourd'hui des jobs payé en
dessous du smic vous ancien ministre du
travail est ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre
non je pense qu'il faut qu'on ouvre un
débat sur l'emploi du genou parce que
c'est un retour de l'intérieur au smic
il faut qu'on ouvre ce débat qu'on ouvre
ce débat parce que c'était le titre du
monde cet après midi au départ manuel
valls d'ailleurs un jeune sur cinq
condamnés jeunes sur presque quatre ans
après trois ans n'a pas non plus stable
et un taux de chômage qui est deux fois
et demie le taux de chômage moyen
national
je les ai vécus comme ministre du
travail à une époque où le chômage était
à 7 ou avec jean louis borloo
nous connaissions la croissance et nous
n'avons pas résolu ni les uns ni les
aurait quand même ouvrir un désagrément
il une idée qui est dans l'air vous êtes
mais c'est pas cette idée là elle n'est
pas aussi simple que cela
les allemands la pratique mais derrière
ou une formation ou un accompagnement ou
un accueil dans l'entreprise en une
politique de logement des jeunes ont une
politique d'accompagnement social le le
salaire est un symbole c'est de
l'accompagnement que général qu'il faut
alors on attendait bien sûr manuel valls
et sur le pacte de responsabilité sur
l'emploi le premier ministre a annoncé
une mesure simple pour alléger le coût
du travail une nécessité at il souligné
on l'écouté vous réagissez gérard
larcher en répondant à déborah claude de
de l' agence france-presse
nous devons aller à l'essentiel et
l'essentiel c'est la france son avenir
sa jeunesse sa force
si nous voulons que la france reste une
nation maîtresse de son destin
nous devons lui rendre la force
économique qu'elle a perdu depuis dix
ans il faut donc produire en france
créer de la richesse en france créer des
emplois durables en france pour faire
reculer le chômage de masse
c'est le but du pacte de responsabilité
proposée par le président de la
république le chômage asom notre pays
depuis des décennies
il s'est aggravé mois après mois depuis
2008 1,3 million de demandeurs d'emploi
supplémentaires en six ans avant que
nous parvenions fin 2013 à ralentir le
rythme
la politique de l'emploi conduit depuis
22 mois en direction des jeunes a eu des
résultats il y a moins de jeunes
chômeurs aujourd'hui qu'il ya un an mais
cela ne suffit pas un jeune français sur
cinq est aujourd'hui condamné au chômage
et sans une croissance plus forte
nous ne ferons rien et la croissance ne
se décrète pas elle se stimulent avec
pragmatisme et avec volontarisme le coût
du travail
il doit baisser c'est un des leviers de
la compétitivité
nous porterons les allégement du coût de
travail à 30 milliards d'ici 2016 au
niveau du smic
les cotisations patronales à lurçat
seront entièrement supprimée au 1er
janvier 2015
zéro charge pour l'employeur d'un
salariés payés au smic
voilà le changement voilà une vraie
révolution
voilà donc l'annoncé phare du premier
ministre ces après midis bonsoir debra
claude votre question donc sur ce point
particulièrement bien sûr c'est une
révolution de supprimer les cotisations
patronales comme nous l'avons j'ai
revécu 2009 en 2009 et les économistes
ont constaté que ça avait sans doute
créer trente mille emplois et donc c'est
une mesure utile forte et que nous
avions déjà utilisé à un moment
difficile mais je pense que si tu aurais
les chiffres ya dix ans manuel valls
mardi à 10 ans et 10 en 2004 à trois
jours près je devenais ministre en
charge des relations du travail avec
jean louis borloo nous avions une
mission
car le taux de chômage était élevé de
faire baisser le chômage et le chômage a
baissé
non pas simplement par notre génie
personnel soyons jeudi humble parce que
ça sujet tellement compliqué tellement
difficile simplement parce que nous
avons eu de la croissance donc
l'objectif c'est de retrouver de la
croissance
à cette époque là nous avons mis en
place des emplois aidés mais nous avons
vu la limite aussi des emplois aidés
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui améliore le
chômage des jeunes mais j'allais dire de
manière très fragile très temporaire
parce que y compris le gouvernement
nouveau dit je voudrais bien que
l'entreprise privée prennent le relais
donc le premier des objectifs c'est la
croissance et la compétitivité des
entreprises et donc la croissance et la
compétitivité
c'est le coût du travail oui il ya aussi
recherche développement qualité des
produits présence pour conquérir les
marchés
ça c'est fait nous avons perdu c'est
drôle les entreprises mais encore
faut-il libéré à l'intérieur des
entreprises les forces nécessaires pour
aller à cette conclusion
ben je ne voterai pas une mesure de
l'alourdissement du travail vous dire
que je voterai l'ensemble je n'en suis
pas certain mais tout ce qui peut aider
à nous rendre compétitif 2004 connie
travail quand ils étaient cent france
ils étaient 150 mg bail aujourd'hui
celle inverse
alors nous avons tous une part de
responsabilité parce que l'imaginaire
sur les impôts nous avons été
particulièrement imaginatifs et ce
gouvernement le gouvernement ayrault l'a
été tout particulièrement sur les autres
renault dit là on peut escompter de
cette mesure annoncée par leur ministre
plusieurs dizaines ont soit le 10
l'expérience sarkozy titre c'était
tranquille emploi très bien avec des
économies rencontre parti qui va falloir
trouver alors c'est un autre sujet 30
milliards cice l'impôt sur les sociétés
que nous avions commencé à mettre en
place avec les penguins
nous avions commencé à voir la
convergence avec l'allemagne
gouvernement ont pensé que nous avions
mis en place un groupe de travail du
sénat
je le rappelle sur ce sujet copier non
mais c'était et plagié dans les non
monsieur pas
mais il ya des convergences qu'il faut
avoir avec des pays qui réussissent à
voir l'impôt sur les sociétés parmi les
plus lourds des pays de l' ocde
nous voyons bien que ça entrave la
compétitivité et ainsi de suite
et donc j'ai estimé que c'était un
effort en direction des entreprises de
50 milliards comment le finance dont on
n'ose pas parler de financement il n'y a
rien sur le financement de cette mesure
est-ce que c'est simplement
l'accroissement de la richesse produite
la valeur ajoutée produite manuel valle
trop c'est ce qui vous a manqué c'est
apprécié ce que j'ai entendu je posais
la question à philippe parini tout
savoir si j'avais eu une part de ma
l'audition elle il m'a dit non non ça va
donc vous êtes convaincu qu'à demi si je
comprends il faut des choses
supplémentaires c'est un vieux problème
c'est pas de combat coûte pas me
convaincre le problème c'est de faire
réussir la france et de faire réussir
les entreprises françaises pas
simplement pour les dividendes des
entreprises parce que créant de la
richesse ils créent de l'emploi en
créant de l'emploi
elle solidifie le modèle social bien si
on peut passer maintenant la vigne en
termes de l'ump autre sujet puisque mais
en même temps l'opposition l'accuse on
est vu le focus on l'a entendu à
l'opposition dans l'hémicycle on y avait
quelques quelques interjections tout à
l'heure à la sobriété
ouais ça vous a gêné alors donc ses
noces et est aussi serein n'en faut dire
que je l'avais je le regardais par
l'assemblée bien sûr rien au sénat par
le premier ministre abhisit
naturellement différent ça ne crée pas
la même ambiance que à propos tenus
directement vous demandez du coup est ce
que les municipales ont un peu revigoré
mp on vous parlait tout à l'heure de
sixième dont souffre le force à 6 et le
force 6
comment vous allez transformer ses
résultats ce que ses résultats ont sauvé
le soldat jean françois copé comment ça
se passe il ya eu des réunions également
en ce moment les cas l'avis de
l'opposition ump udi divers droite
c'est naturellement on l'a presque
oublié avec la mise en place de son
gouvernement
formidable succès 62% des villes depuis
de 9000 habitants sont clairement des
villes qui se réclame d'élus de
l'opposition nationale et on n'a pas
évoqué aussi la victoire de tout le
monde et d'abord de candidats sur le
terrain c'est aussi la victoire de la
capacité à se rassembler entre deux
familles politiques de s'ouvrir à des
personnalités de la société civile
il faut avoir une vision et puis
beaucoup de chefs lieux de canton petite
ville entre par le peu qu'ils ont
basculé avec notamment le sentiment du
territoire rural d'être oubliés
abandonné méprisé certains c'est
vraiment ce qu'ils avaient ressenti vous
dit à la fin du gouvernement héros vous
dites une vague de force si certains
disent une vague bleue mais très vague
parce que dans le parti certains parlent
même d'une victoire par défaut oui enfin
écoutez moi qui suis d'origine paysanne
j'ai compté dans la colonne du silo que
nous avions 62 % des communes de plus de
9000 et écoutez c'est ce qui est acquis
et ça veut dire par différence qu'il
n'ya que 38%
combien de plus de neuf victoires
également du président l'ump qui a
beaucoup fait parler lecture de
l'ensemble semaine
le président du mpla puis contribuer
comme do françois fillon bruno le maire
xavier bertrand bernard accoyer moi même
et bien d'autres on a fait notre devoir
ce dont on s'est aperçu sur le terrain
que c'était d'abord de concret qu'il
fallait parler savez les gens
première question c'était l'emploi
s'était pas l'ump
c'était la cohésion j'ai trouvé une
france très divisés d'ailleurs le
premier ministre a dit très très divisés
sur les sujets de société
c'était aussi la question de sécurité et
puis du sentiment des territoires qu'ils
n'étaient pas autour de grandes
agglomérations d'être oubliés abandonnés
c'est vraiment les quatre choses que je
me suis promené de calais à la bourgogne
à chambéry en passant par l'ouest
j'ai terminé ma campagne symboliquement
à quimper rendez compte le vendredi soir
une ville symbole de la bascule la ville
de monsieur ludovic jolivet aujourd'hui
on va revenir à paris au siège de l'ump
c'est un peu plus laisser passer des
choses qu'elle était engagée
je crois qu'il ya eu une réunion ce
matin d'après ce que j'ai tous les
mardis matin tous les mardis matins vous
étiez présent l'union elle s'est bien
passé on a dit qu'alain juppé avait un
peu tapé du poing sur la table
concernant l'organisation interne du
parti à l'arrivée d'une réunion
notamment aux jean françois copé devait
faire la clarté sur la présence n'a qu
on est content de présenter des comptes
vous émettez convaincu de l'ump après
les accusations de favoritisme à tous
les cas les comptes qui nous ont été
présentés nous ont été présentés nous
sont transmis il ya des murs et j'allais
dire le mérite c'est la présentation des
comptes
après il faudra aller les analyser mais
c'était une demande qui avait été faite
depuis longtemps qu' un certain nombre
de membres de ce bureau stratégie que
françois fillon avait réitéré la semaine
il n'était pas là donc il avait prévenu
qu'il serait pas là d'accord mais a tout
de même des choses c'est que à la jupe
et avec d'autres ont fait partie
nous avons souhaité tout simplement que
les statuts soient appliquées et
notamment pour le bureau politique qui a
été votée au mois de janvier dernier et
que soit mis en place ce qui n'exclut
pas cette réunion stratégique ce qui
n'exclut pas des réunions plus énergie
mec
alain juppé a rappelé qu'il y avait des
statuts son rôle de fondateurs
d'autoriser la lenteur d alain juppé
était bien présent si je comprends bien
vous avez dit que tant qu' ils se parent
élu maire de bordeaux je consacrais mais
il est bien de retour apparemment est
plutôt parce qu'il est il est cette
semaine ces dernières semaines ces deux
dernières semaines en très bonne place
dans les sondages
alain juppé il est donné l'homme
politique préféré des français devrait
même os et donc moi je vous savez alain
juppé fait partie des référendums notre
mouvement politique et c'est un homme
solide et je suis très heureux qu'il se
partage entre bordeaux et aussi sa
famille parce que sa famille politique
il est de ceux qui ont été les
bâtisseurs de l'ump et à voir la jupe et
parmi les scores en vue de 2017 il aura
selon vous l'occasion de démontrer qu'il
est le meilleur d'entre nous qu'on avait
déjà cher jours chaque jour nous
prendrons ya des primaires organisées je
fais partie de la commission de réforme
du statut seront candidats aux primaires
ceux qui le souhaitent et ensuite ça se
déroulera normalement votre candidat
c'est toujours moi je pense à temps des
problèmes si on veut savoir quel cheval
je soutiens j'appartiens d'abord
connaissait bien les écuries monsieur h
mais bien sûr monsieur c'est clair moi
depuis très longtemps avec philippe
seguin
françois fillon nous avons travaillé
ensemble j'ai aussi travaillé avec alain
juppé
chacun connaît ma fibre de gaulliste
social c'est autour de ça que je serai
et celui qui sera choisi sera celui que
je soutiens 1 je n'ai pas de changement
de cap dans ma sensibilité pas bien
remplie et donc soutenu françois fillon
est un pur hasard j'étais très proche de
philippe seguin pardon une échéance un
peu plus proche les européennes vous
allez voter pour monsieur lamassoure je
vais soutenir alain lamassoure et tout
le centre est très important c'est que
nous définissions la ligne politique sur
l'europe de l'ump c'est d'ailleurs un
des sujets
sur lequel le bureau politique devra se
prononcer il rassemble les sensibilités
différentes et personnellement je serai
dans la région ile-de-france ordonna
lamassoure
comme dans d'autres régions aux côtés de
nos candidats comme deborah vous posez
la question parce qu'à votre place ici
même la semaine dernière gérard larcher
il y avait henri guaino qui nous a
annoncé je ne crains pas le buzz et je
peux vous annoncer que je ne mettrai pas
un bulletin ump dans l'urne je ne
voterai pas la nation pour lui c'est
l'horreur du fait de l'arrêt du
fédéralisme européen
que répondez vous avec à votre droite
parlementaire voisins des yvelines
moi qui étais président du comité des
maires du non à maastricht
je n'ai aucune difficulté à soutenir
alain lamassoure à la condition que nous
définissions ensemble l'ump dans la
diversité de ce que nous sommes
un projet politique pour le faire dans
les cages hausse de 15 ans viennent et
ça me semble important et je suis
certain qu'elle ait lamassoure prendre
en compte le projet d'ailleurs il l'a
dit la semaine dernière en commission
d'investiture donc y aura une ligne
politique
c'est une politique nous allons peser un
certain nombre sur la définition de
cette ligne politique mais
personnellement moi qui étais fervents
du non à maastricht pour des raisons de
cohérence sociale et cohérence politique
on le voit bien la peau sur les sociétés
partir du mans il est très différent en
allemagne et en france
comment voulez-vous vous y retrouver à
terme dans une monnaie unique
nous avons la nécessité de ces
convergences d'ailleurs pour ça que nous
étions posé à lyon l'idée aussi c'est
j'imagine de faire en sorte que le front
national ne soit n'arrive pas en premier
au soir du 25 mai l'objectif c'est qu'un
maximum de français adhèrent à notre
projet voilà pourquoi je faisais partie
aussi de ceux qui ça n'avait pas été
l'époque retenu penser que dans deux ou
trois régions il n'était peut-être pas
inutile que nous fassions je le répète
une liste commune avec nos amis dit on
va vous demander une et j'ai toujours
défendu donc c'est pas quelques jours
mais c'est trop tard
avant jean louis ne soit malade jeunes
avaient prôné que dehors je pensais dans
la région nord-ouest la région sud est
il aurait été intéressant dans d'autres
régions peut-être était-il intéressant
d'avoir deux listes à continue pour moi
d'être une vraie interrogation parce que
nous avions gagné la précédente élection
européenne parce que nous étions
rassemblés au 6e 10 a fait plus de
sièges finalement avec la proportion oui
bah ça n'est pas que ça c'est aussi un
message
quel est le message de la france demain
dans les institutions européennes
quel est le message de la france au
parlement européen est ce une france
frileuse recroquevillé ou une france qui
croit en elle moi qui suis pour la
souveraineté de mon pays je crois que la
souveraineté de mon pays c'est de sortir
de ce cycle de dettes de ce cycle de
décroissance de ce cycle eux ou au fond
aux comptes peut pas ce qui m'attriste
quand on voit le dossier le dossier
ukrainien
c'est de voir aujourd'hui c'est
l'allemagne et ça n'est plus le couple
franco-allemand qui joue un rôle majeur
donc je suis certain qu'il nous faut
porter un message ou la france
la france a besoin de l'europe et
l'europe a besoin de la france
très bien merci d'abord à perrine
tarneaud arrive maintenant on va parler
de la mer du sénat gérard larcher
puisque les calculs indiquent un
basculement va dire probables possibles
voire certains homos de 70 dès le mois
de septembre
d'où un jeu subtil qui se met en place
du côté de l'ump et des centristes
évidemment on voit ça avec jérôme rabier
la vague bleue des municipales passées
cap sur la haute assemblée pour l'ump
jean claude gaudin réélu triomphalement
à marseille mais non candidat au plateau
mais tout de même en garde ses collègues
c'est à la portée de la droite
républicaine et du centre si nous ne
faisons pas trop de bêtises surtout de
la modestie surtout du travail surtout
de la préparation et pas de fanfaronnade
avec la réforme du scrutin sénatorial
c'est une vingtaine de sièges que la
droite et le centre doivent conquérir
pour reprendre la majorité
forts de leur bon score aux municipales
les centristes veulent peser davantage
et dresse le portrait idéal d'un
président du sénat de droite passer
obligatoirement un président consensuel
un président aussi qui renforce le sénat
dans les institutions politiques
françaises un rôle que gérard larcher
connaît bien lui qui a déjà dû composer
avec les centristes de 2008 à 2011 avant
de perdre le sénat
contrairement à jean pierre bel qui n'a
jamais eu de majorité stable lors de son
mandat en jeu crois qu'on voit la
différence entre la période 2008-2011
ces 2011 2014
on voit bien que monsieur larcher a été
un excellent président du sénat
officiellement en campagne depuis
février ils devraient être confrontés
comme en 2008 à jean pierre raffarin
l'ancien premier ministre
omniprésent ces derniers temps au sénat
la firme on peut être en campagne sans
être candidat déclaré manière à peine
voilée de critiquer la candidature
précoce de gérard larcher
ce qui compte c'est la crédibilité du
sénat et la respectabilité des sénateurs
et donc c'est un projet qui doit être un
projet d'alternance ce projet là et doit
être collectif et juste à manger relâché
ya toute sa place au groupe ump du sénat
les grandes manoeuvres ne font que
commencer et devrait s'accélérer une
fois les élections européennes du mois
de mai prochain passé voilà
on connait tous un des mystères du sénat
après les européennes et vous serez
candidat plus que jamais à la présidence
du sénat c'est pas le sujet puisque
c'est un sujet que j'ai traité il ya
longtemps
le sujet c'est aujourd'hui de construire
une nouvelle majorité au sénat
c'est de construire aussi un projet par
le sénat qui soit pas l'espèce de
projets de revanche parce que parce que
le sujet
quel rôle et quelle course et d'arrivée
des mots durs pour le sénat à gauche
oui on va parler d'un cénacle
bicamérisme le bicamérisme c'est quelque
chose d'important et j'ai vu que même si
je crois savoir que monsieur valls a eu
quelques tentations
il n'a pas touché ou bicamérisme des
tentations pour tous les cas j'ai
tellement mauvais souvenir de sa
participation au débat il s'adressait
d'ailleurs au président d'un groupe où
les radicaux de gauche majoritaires
quand il avait dit vous pouvez toujours
débattre un sabbat aucune allée du débat
sur la limitation du cumul est bien sûr
mais c'était aussi le dire
on peut dire la même chose dans le
respect du mécanisme et puis qui sera
produit pour le sénat en matière de
représentation du territoire de
prospective
c'est tout ça qui est posée c'est
d'abord à ça qu'il va falloir répondre
avec a besoin du territoire du
territoire rural mais aussi du
territoire urbain d'être représentés
d'autant que le sénat avec la réforme du
quinquennat ne peut pas être le clone de
l'assemblée nationale alors et sa team
sujet fondamental plus important que de
savoir tout pourra sortir de primaire il
ya des hommes et des femmes de qualité
alors à partir de ce que vous dites de
questions à d'une part sur manuel vals
vous me dites quand même qu'il a eu une
volonté peut-être ce week-end de
travailler sur une offre sérieuse
quelques rumeurs nous était arrivé
quelques rumeurs 2 et y est arrivé
peut-être une tentation italienne mais
l'histoire italienne est complètement
différent puisque le sénat italien était
levé été élu au suffrage universel
direct avec des pouvoirs égaux nous
sommes dans une situation complètement
différente les spectateurs nocives
l'italie vient de voter une réforme
effectivement des prix est en train de
voter on va dire avec la fin du pouvoir
législatif pour le sénat italien sur le
show du bicamérisme voilà ceci dit
françois hollande c'était quand même
engagé sur des points précis notamment
sur la diminution du nombre de
parlementaires est ce que ça vous seriez
prêt à le suivre sur la diminution du
nombre de sénateurs ou les débats sur
légitime
je rappelle que c'est françois
mitterrand qui a largement augmenté le
nombre de députés le jour il a créé et
souvenez-vous la proportionnelle pour
tenter de se maintenir au pouvoir parce
que ça c'est une réalité ce sont les
socialistes qui ont augmenté le nombre
de parlementaires nicolas sarkozy non il
va prélever pour laisser naître pour les
députés car représentant français à
l'étranger et non il a pris sur le
préciput nombreux créé par françois
mitterrand vous dites vous devrez pas un
sénat de 2 la revanche mais vous dites
ça parce que vous avez été battus comme
président du sénat donc c'est plus
difficile en revenir dans la course
pas du tout je ne veux pas nationale 2
la revanche parce que j'ai à un espèce
de souvenirs étrange des six mois
précédant l'élection présidentielle ou
ici on a été le laboratoire du holland
his soul des veaux on a cassé la réforme
territoriale la suppression de la
compétence générale
la suppression du conseiller territorial
tout ça le sénat pour préparer
l'élection du président de la république
sénat de gauche et le seul moment
d'ailleurs eu là une majorité et après
le sénat n'a pas été en capacité
le sénat de gauche de dégager des
majorités pour voter les choses aussi
important que le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
le projet de loi de finances mais aussi
un certain nombre de textes fondamentaux
la droite va certainement devenir
majoritaire en septembre à bordeaux de
jean claude gaudin mais pas de
fanfaronnade cette majorité sera aussi
tenue et donc votre marge de manoeuvre
pour la droite pour les centristes et
l'ump aussi ce ne sera pas forcément
plus facile alors qu'elle peut être vous
dites que vous réfléchissez aujourd'hui
à une autre conception du rôle et de la
place du sénat dans la mairie
maintenant qu'à des institutions là
c'est quoi je pense qu'un dialogue qui
n'existe pas c'est quand même assez
paradoxale entre le président du sénat
me semble-t-il président de l'assemblée
nationale les cas qui n'apparaît pas ça
fait partie des choses qu'il faut
inventer imaginer
je pense qu'il ya des majorités d'idées
qu'on peut dégager ici qui dépasse les
seules limites de la majorité de
l'opposition que ce travail là ce projet
précédent c'est ce qu'il nous faut
proposer le vrai pouvoir législatif
aujourd'hui c'est claude bartolone qui
le détient bien sûr c'est évident
puisqu'il n'ya pas de capacité à dégager
de majorité
ici donc je pense qu'il faut un autre
manière de dire vous êtes très critique
sur le bilan de jean pierre bel la 4e
journée ça je crois on a vu que respect
parce que nos relations sont convenables
mais pardonnez moi je suis un homme
politique qu'est ce que je constate
c'est un cdh a aujourd'hui qui n'est
plus reconnu qui est abaissée dans sa
fonction
donc pendant le sentiment y compris
quand on va chez des amis au moment des
élections municipales mais à quoi vous
servez et donc ça c'est une vraie
question il faut qu'on y réponde
nous n'avons pas le droit vis-à-vis des
français parce que je crois profondément
au rôle du sénat balancier stabilisateur
des institutions qui dans ce qui n'est
pas le clone de l'assemblée nationale
l'assemblée nationale c'est la réplique
sismique de l'élection présidentielle
nous devons être autre chose
nous ne devons pas être simplement un
espèce de senna uniquement de groupe
politique qu'ils s'opposeraient les a
forcément une assemblée politique aussi
c'est une semblait prendre l'époque
évoqué henri de raincourt
regardez sur les questions de libertés
individuelles et collectives le sénat
souvent eu des positions différentes et
sur le fond très différente de ce que tu
étais pour mercredi avec des
propositions du gouvernement de françois
fillon et d'écolo sarkozy donc vous
aimeriez que le salon retrouve cette
voie là aujourd'hui c'est parce que le
sénat à l'apei angoissé dans un pays
divisé en un pays qui a un manque de
cohésion sociale et territoriale
il a apporté des réponses ouais juste
pour revenir sur quand même la course à
la présidence du sénat je suis désolé
beaucoup les esprits vous avez quand
même dit que vous étiez candidat
elle suscite l'intérêt d'une certaine
manière pour l'inscription je les dis à
une époque on ne pensait pas reconquérir
le sénat dans ces conditions la halle au
moins le mérite avant gardiste
maintenant maintenant qu'on a joué une
époque et qu'il l'alternance est
possible en septembre est ce que vous
confirmez que vous êtes toujours
intéressé par le poste
aujourd'hui je l'aiderai février
d'accord je n'ai pas de bégaiement jean
pierre raffarin visiblement tout laisse
à penser qu'il a aussi envie de se
représenter
qu'est ce qui vous différencie
finalement et ed déjà apte à jouer
jean pierre raffarin gérard larcher oui
vous ajouter d'autres non et bien sûr il
ya eu philippe marini il y en a d'autres
au fond c'est nos collectionneurs qui
choisiront celle ou celui qu'ils
considéreront comme répondant le mieux
n'oublions pas nos amis centristes nos
amis non-inscrits tous ceux qui ont
envie de se retrouver
c'est un sujet c'est pas le sujet numéro
un d'abord un projet pour le sénat
deuxièmement gagnons les élections
sénatoriales gagnons les élections
sénatoriales et ensuite les collègues
anciens et nouveaux feront un choix mais
ce choix nous le respecterons
et pas un drame nous l'avons vécu
davantage c'est que nous avons une
méthode qui a été mis au point il ya six
ans qui a bien fonctionné
et cette méthode a ses règles restent
tournés et insolent vivre à tout ça
sereinement en bien sûr ça fera quelques
titres quelques émissions mais tout ça
c'est bien parce que c'est la vie
démocrate est plus présent on sent
l'alternance possible en septembre
prochain
je suis pour 2011 vous avez quand même
reproché de ne pas avoir vu venir la
défaite d'avoir bien sûr je me suis
trompé de 4 ou saint siège qui étaient
liés la plupart du temps nos divisions
mais aussi à ce qui se passait dans le
ressenti des élus par rapport au
sentiment d'abandon du territoire peux
vous dire aujourd'hui que c'est encore
beaucoup plus prévenants efforts il faut
prendre en compte
moi j'écoute le territoire
il ya beaucoup de terrain j'en ai
commencé mais je vais commencer je n'ai
jamais su c'est l'impression que ce
ressenti des élus du terrain contre le
gouvernement actuel va peut-être
s'accentuer avec la réforme des
collectivités telle qu'elle a été
annoncée aujourd'hui par ailleurs je
pense qu'il ya jamais dire il n'y a pas
de dialogue entre eux mais je vois que
c'est madame lebranchu qui a conduit
nous précédons diallo qui en fait n'a
pas existé entre le territoire je
rappelle que nous sommes à la quatrième
réforme en 20 mois qui nous est proposé
cdc réforme et ses réformes
rien que sur le sujet de la compétence
département région elles se sont annulés
les unes les autres
il va falloir que le premier ministre
donne à peu de cohérence et tout ça
c'est sa volonté manifestement on
l'avait souvent ça m'apparaît
indispensable mais quand il annonce une
nouvelle carte de l'intercommunalité en
on en a déjà une pour 2016 l'anoci
nouvelle carte de l'intercommunalité
pour 2010 comment voulez vous que le
territoire qui est le seul endroit tu
peux porter notamment le dynamisme
économique la reprise de la croissance
celle ayant le face sereinement
on ne sera même pas qu'ils seront les
responsables de ce territoire en 2018 on
a besoin de sérénité
on a besoin d'une certaine forme de
tranquillité
non en fait la dernière réforme qui a
vraiment fonctionné
c'est la réforme chevènement sur les
intercommunalités je pense qu'on a eu
tort
moi je n'étais qu'un converti de gomel
conseiller territorial peut-être un
débat juste et je pense que c'était une
bonne réforme
je le dis d'autant plus qu' il fallu du
temps pour convaincre
un mot pour finir sur jean louis borloo
il ya eu encore plusieurs hommages
rendus cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle
exactement mais aussi de claude
bartolone le président l'assemblée
nationale vous qui avez travaillé main
dans la main longtemps avec lui
est ce que c'est la tristesse qui
prévaut ce soir donne là de ne pas
l'avoir vu et entendu dans l'hémicycle
de l'assemblée c'est d'abord de l'amitié
que j'ai pour jean-louis tous coups de c
elle a dépassé de travail politique nous
avons été un député trop rares couples
ministre
elle est vraiment très bien entendu nous
sommes complémentaires nous restions de
complémentaire dans nos sensibilités le
seul message c'est un message d'amitié
dire à jean louis tu te remet bien vite
et puis tu aura sans doute à un rôle à
jouer c'est le seul message que j'ai à
lui transmettre
c'est vraiment ce message là aujourd'hui
allez jean louis qui va il avait une
manière très particulière de faire de la
politique un oui il avait aussi une
amitié quand on était son ami et quand
on est son ami vous voyez c'est quelque
chose de fort et jean louis c'est
quelqu'un dont je sais que la force de
vie et est au dessus de tous voilà
pourquoi je lui dans son message
l'amitié et j'ai envie que de travis et
vous avez la lourde trouvé bien vite
bien sûr quand vous étiez effectivement
fusionnelle on peut le dire un drame qui
investissent durable tandis que c'était
une complémentarité en politique
notamment quand on travaille en fait
parce que jean-louis c'est un type
exceptionnel et par moments il
m'énervait aussi mais l'amitié permet
aux habits de tout se dire
et donc j'ai envie qui m'énerve voila
voila je suis sûr qu'il va m'énerver bas
et côté on veut on le fait pour lui
d'abord leur design et il a décidé de
tourner la page et c'est une chose mais
l'amitié
ça dépasse la politique à nos moeurs et
peut-être que c'est peut-être une
occasion pour les politiques de
réfléchir parce que décidant de
jean-louis elle ne m'étonne pas elle est
forte les un message et elle est aussi
quelque part un espèce de 2 2 halo de
lumière sur une politique que parfois on
montre trop dans ces images négatives
gembrie nous donne une sacrée leçon
d'hommes et ça c'est jean-louis merci
merci pour lui
merci gérard larcher merci perrine a
très vite
le